the search for the suspect in a shooting
at a Tennessee Waffle House is over
police arrested Travis Ranking not far
from his apartment just a few hours ago
correspondent Jonathan Serrie joins us
live from Antioch with more on how it
all came to an end today
good evening Jonathan good evening Brett
until this afternoon police say they had
had received no credible sightings of
the suspect but they continue to focus
their search area here in Antioch
Tennessee very close to the scene of the
crime this Waffle House you see behind
me and today their efforts paid off
video from an eyewitness's smartphone
shows suspect Travis ranking in police
custody minutes after his arrest in the
wooded area near this apartment complex
not far from the Waffle House where a
mass shooting claimed the lives of four
people early Sunday morning in the
Nashville suburb of Antioch detective
williams saw his face and realized that
that is the suspect we were looking for
at that point detective williams drew
down on the suspect the suspect prone
doubt he's on get on the ground he got
on the ground immediately prone himself
out prior to Sunday shooting ranking was
no stranger to law enforcement back in
his home state of Illinois this 2016
police report explained
Travis J Reinking was delusional and
believe the famous entertainer Taylor
Swift was harassing him via stalking and
hacking his phone the following year the
Secret Service arrested him for refusing
to leave a restricted area near the
White House that prompted authorities to
seize Ryan Kings guns and place them in
his father's custody but they say the
father eventually returned the weapons
to his son
including the ar-15 used at the Waffle
House it is possible if you try
weapons normally to a person that is
prohibited Swiper could potentially be a
violation of federal law three people
died at the scene and a fourth at the
hospital police say it could have been
even worse if it hadn't been for the
quick action of a customer who decided
to rush the gunman as he appeared to be
reloading or unjam inhibit I managed to
get him with one hand on the gun and did
not grab it from him not threw it over
the countertop and after his arrest Ron
King immediately requested an attorney
and made no statements to police he
faces four counts of criminal homicide
Brett Jonathan Serrie and Tennessee
tonight Jonathan thank you